jetzt schauen wir uns dieses Video auch
an über das ganz Deutschland spricht
zwei 13-jährige Mädchen schlagen brutal
auf eine 14-Jährige ein sehen Sie diese
Bilder sie treten mit den Füßen das
Mädchen des Landes mit schweren
Verletzungen im Krankenhaus und
drumherum stehen Passanten Film schauen
zu aber keiner greift ein was schockiert
mehr worüber ist man fast mehr entsetzt
über die Brutalität der Mädchen oder
darüber dass niemand hilft Herr Bruder
ich weiß nicht ich mag auch das Video
nicht gucken weil ich das so gruselig
finde für mich stellt sich nicht die
Frage wer da schuldig oder noch
Schuldiger ist ich finde es einfach das
ist eine kleine Fußnote zu der
Verrohrung die wir seit langem erleben
darüber gibt es viele Spekulationen
woher die Verrohung kommt erstmal hat
das was mit dem empowerment zu tun das
was Frauen aus Parlament machen ist
vermutlich auch davon abhängig aus
welchen Milieus sie kommen in der
Unterschied macht das vielleicht
tatsächlich eine Form von einem
Parlament sein fürchte ich und das
zweite ist dass niemand eingreift diese
Gesellschaft ist so gründlich
pazifiziert worden dass Leute an der
Gewalt vorbeischauen es genügt nicht nur
darüber hinwegzusehen dass die Ukraine
massakriert wird wir schauen auch weg
wenn der Nachbars Kind
zusammengeschlagen wird das sind für
mich die unmittelbaren Folgen des
gesellschaftlichen Pazifismus das ist
gar nicht so weit weg von ihnen das ist
in Badener Württemberg in Rastatt
wirklich auch in der Provinz hätten sie
das dort erwartet oder vermutet man
solche Bilder nicht eher aus dem
Großstädten
nein ich glaube Leute die in dem Bereich
also professionell arbeiten erleben das
schon auch dass diese Hemmschwelle
einfach auch singt
das ist glaube ich schon ein allgemeines
Problem ich meine das war wirklich
Dritte gegen den Kopf also der ist schon
der tötungskuppel eigentlich schon
sehr tief wo ich mal sagen man kann es
kaum ertragen das haben wir hier gerade
auch gesagt Frau Schüler diese Bilder
die wir da gerade gesehen haben und die
Kinder und Jugend Brutalität die steigt
an in den vergangenen fünf Jahren
besonders unter den 14-jährigen junge
Kinder hätten sie eingegriffen trauen
wir uns nicht mehr einzugreifen wenn man
da in diesem Bahnhof steht und so eine
Szene beobachtet
also ich finde dieses Video auch
schockierend und ich glaube ich hätte
eingegriffen also schon aus dem Impuls
raus weil ich das auch jetzt bei mir
merke und Geduld und natürlich auch
sofort die Polizei gerufen ich kann es
gar nicht verstehen dass man das filmt
aber nichts tut das kann ich wirklich
nicht verstehen ich fürchte
wir haben es auch mit einem mit so einer
also das wirkt ja so ein bisschen als
wollten den Computer spielen nachspielen
ja und diese diese diese verschwinden
zwischen Realität und dem was man
irgendwie zu Hause irgendwie am
Computerbildschirm macht das scheint mir
auch für viele ein Problem zu sein also
dass da Realität und und Spiel völlig
ähm
völlig ineinander verschwimmen und man
überhaupt nicht mehr dass diese Empathie
hat Schmerz zu empfinden und auch zu
empfinden dass andere Schmerzen haben
das ist ja über die dieses Mädchen am
Boden das hat wahrscheinlich brüllende
Schmerzen hat schwere Verletzungen und
das ist da nicht mehr diese natürliche
Hemmschwelle gibt aufzuhören
das finde ich ist ein riesen Problem ich
meine das ist jetzt kein tägliche
Geschichte und ich glaube es hat auch
nichts mit Frauen in powerment zu tun in
dieser tägliche Geschichte es wird noch
nicht täglich berichtet täglichen
Brutalität wahrscheinlich nicht aber
diese Tendenz zur verrogen die sehe ich
auch die sehe ich auch und ich glaube es
hat auch was damit zu tun dass man genau
solche Fragen von
aufeinander achten
Wertschätzung dass das auch zu wenig
eine Rolle spielt und dass diese diese
dieser pausenlose Druck und gleichzeitig
so eine gewisse Vereinsamung vor Medien
dieses dieses Empathie dieses
miteinander sprechen
hätten sie eingegriffen das muss man
sich auch trauen viele sagen oh weh ich
habe Angst dass ich da selber verletzt
werde oder dass ich damit rein hätten
sie eingegriffen was hätten sie getan
also zumindest wäre das mein Anspruch da
einzugreifen das ist jetzt immer etwas
hypothetisch zu sagen was hätte man
gemacht man ich kenne jetzt ja genauso
wie alle hier in der Runde und nur diese
Video Schnipsel und dieser Ausschnitte
nicht das was drumherum geschehen ist
aber das sollte zumindest der Anspruch
eines jeden Bürgers sein in Deutschland
dann da auch einzugreifen und dazwischen
zu gehen oder zumindest schnell die
Polizei zu rufen und andere auch zu
aktivieren anstatt so etwas auch noch zu
filmen da sind wir uns völlig einig was
ist das Gefährt hat finde ich sehr
begrüßenswert auf diese Weise für mich
erst oder helfe ich erst ne also nein
die Frage hat sich dadurch schon
beantwortet dass sie gefilmt hat wenn er
erst hilft und dann anfängt zu viel man
ist Situation vorbei aber was ich gerne
wissen möchte weiß man was mit den
Hintergrund woher kommen diese Mädchen
was für
Erziehung hatten sie und was
nur noch ein Punkt machen der wichtig
ist weil das ist ja ein Fall der auch
möglicherweise für viele andere Fälle in
Deutschland steht und häufig ist auch
der Umgang dann mit solchen Gewalttätern
mit solchen Straftätern zu lasch da
werden nicht Grenzen aufgezeigt und das
Signal was auch gerade an gewaltbereite
Jugendliche geht ist häufig ihr könnt
das machen ihr kommt dann sowieso
schnell wieder frei oder ist passiert
nicht und das animiert natürlich einige
auch noch so brutal vorzugehen und
deswegen glaube ich muss der recht Staat
auch solchen gewaltbereiten Jugendlichen
härter und deutlicher die Grenzen auch
neue Erkenntnis für die CDU na für die
CDU gar nicht wir haben das ja selber
auch in vielen Bundesländern umgesetzt
und so gehandelt das war immer etwas was
wir gefordert haben ich komme aus
Hamburg da haben wir das selber ja
erlebt wir waren zur Jahrtausendwende
Hauptstadt des Verbrechens das war
damals
das unrühmliche Schlagwort was ich der
SPD Senat erarbeitet hatte und dann
haben wir genau da auch viel härter
agiert und gesagt der Rechtsstaat darf
sich so etwas nicht gefallen lassen und
die Zahlen sind dann auch zurückgegangen
das können Sie auch in anderen Ländern
sehen also zum Beispiel Bayern ist da
auch immer sehr konsequent aber leider
wird das nicht überall so praktiziert
gerade hier in Berlin um 13-jährige
Mädchen da greift gar keinen Star Wars
vielleicht da ist ihm tatsächlich Hilfe
zu Erziehung dringend angesagt und eine
Überprüfung wie konnte es dazu kommen
warum sind 13-jährige Mädchen in der
Lage so etwas zu tun
Entschuldigung ja das ist üblicher
begriff dass da
entsprechend erstens geguckt wird aus
welchem Elternhaus kommen sie braucht es
da Unterstützung des Elternhauses
braucht es möglicherweise also
noch nie so viele Erziehungshilfe
gegeben hat wie heute noch nie so viele
Sozialarbeiter Helfer Familie
es ist nie genug für diese Gesellschaft
kann es gar nicht genug Sozialarbeiter
geben und das ist kein neues Phänomen
neues das eine gewisse Intensität in der
Berichterstattung stattfindet es werden
unglaublich viele Sachen unter den
Teppich gekehrt und das gilt auch leider
für mein Gewerbe in diesem Dorf wie ist
das in Ibbenbüren Illertissen nein ich
meine das andere sehen sie so viel
Auswahl haben wir schon an diesem Tag
bestanden hat ein 17-jähriger Schüler
seine Lehrerin gestochen und dann hat
die Polizei angerufen bis jetzt wissen
wir nichts über die Hintergründe wieso
bleibt die Öffentlichkeit still wenn Sie
nicht über solche Vorfälle informiert
würden das passiert laufend
mehr auf die Hintergründe schon und ich
glaube was uns hier auch an diesem Tisch
eint mehr Zivilcourage denn dann hätte
das Kind ist im Krankenhaus ist gelandet
mit schweren Verletzungen wurde
inzwischen wieder entlassen Gott sei
Dank nein nein
der Position dass er uns nicht die
wilcourage wird in Deutschland mit
Preisen belohnt aber es gibt keine
selbst die Polizei zwei rät nicht
dazwischen zu gehen und vorher noch 110
anzurufen Zivilcourage in diesem Land
ist eine solchen Seltenheit wie der Mut
sich gegen die vorherrschende Meinung zu
stellen
bin ich direkt bei Ihnen Mut sich gegen
vorherrschende Meinung zur Stelle sind
wir nämlich hier Bruder ich gehe direkt
rein in ihr Thema hat unter Frank das
genau haben sie nämlich gemacht sie
haben während der corona-pandemie der
Regierung immer ganz genau auf die
Finger geschaut haben gewarnt wurden
dafür auch stark kritisiert sie sagen
jetzt die Impfung die ist
brandgefährlich sie stützen sich dabei
auf Obduktionen das ist ihr Thema das
ist ihre Zeit